Hồi hợp dùng lúc của quả xa an lòng,
nhiều căn nhà bị tốc mái chỉ trong ít phút.
Mùi lớn cẹm dùng lúc bất ngờ của quả ấp nhất,
chưa mùi chính thương, khiến bốn mùi chính căn nhà bị anh hường,
trong đó mùi bề căn bị tốc mái hoàn toàn.
Nè, là xọc dùng lòng,
kính ý là bình dường nó cũng dùng quả hống sao?
Quới nay tử dụng nghe là cực hơi kỳ lắm,
tự tơ là bài lũi và tơ nó là mùi nè.
Kể giả nhạy sao thì đúng mình chết,
có thể bị trái nhà sau không có tránh này mà cũng nghĩ chết không có thể tránh rồi mình là đỡ.
Vô việc không gây thị thịt về người,
tổng thịt thịt ước tính hơn tắm trong trộn đồng.
Chính quyền điều phương của người dân đang sọn dẹp xưa chữa nhạc rồi.